momento de hablar de economía en directo
América y por ello le doy la bienvenida
a mi compañera Daniela hablando Daniela
muy buenos días Hola Andrés Buenos días
Daniela hasta América Latina llega la
preocupación por el vertido de agua que
planea hacer Japón desde fukushima
cuéntenos pues Andrés lo hemos venido
hablando durante los últimos días Y es
que el gobierno japonés planea comenzar
esta liberación de agua a partir de
agosto desde la central nuclear
destruida por el terremoto y posterior
tsunami en 2011 un plan que todavía
necesita la aprobación oficial del
organismo regulador nuclear nacional que
se espera para este viernes los
sindicatos de pescadores japoneses se
han opuesto durante mucho tiempo y
varios países prohibieron algunos
productos alimenticios japoneses esto
por temor a la radiación pero esta es
una preocupación que ya trasciende
fronteras en Perú Los Pescadores del
puerto morosama en la sureña provincia
de tacna creen que este vertimiento en
el océano Pacífico afectará su sustento
y por eso piden intervención de las
autoridades
nuestro país tiene que pedir pues no a
las organizaciones internacionales tanto
la ONU la FAO la oea para que realmente
ellos evalúen la situación en el cual
Japón quiere soltar estas aguas
contaminantes porque hay que entender
que el planeta el mar es de todos los
seres humanos no de un país Daniela
ahora qué países ven en peligro su
seguridad alimentaria pues este no es
solamente asunto de Los Pescadores
japoneses algunos países vecinos también
ven amenazas al medio ambiente china es
el mayor crítico y ha amenazado con
tomar medidas si el plan sigue adelante
de hecho Beijing prohíbe ya las
importaciones de productos del mar desde
diez prefecturas de Japón incluidas
fukushima y la capital Tokio también en
Corea del Sur la gente ha comenzado a
comprar sal y mariscos en exceso esto
para no hacerlo Después del vertido en
cambiamos de tema vamos a latinoamérica
culminó la Cumbre de jefes de estado de
mercosura qué conclusiones se llegó en
términos económicos pues Andrés esta
cumbre de dos días concluyó en iguazú
Puerto iguazú en Argentina allí el
bloque latinoamericano conformado por
Argentina Brasil Paraguay y Uruguay fue
muy insistente en sus peticiones a la
Unión Europea para que agilice la
ratificación del acuerdo comercial
pendiente desde 2019 entonces el
presidente de Brasil es Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva dijo que no hay más
excusas para no hacerlo y Alberto
Fernández de Argentina quien le entregó
la presidencia temporal del bloque a su
colega aseguró que la culpa es de los
europeos Nadie puede condenarnos a ser
proveedores de la materia prima que
otros industrializan y luego nos venden
a precios exorbitantes nosotros buscamos
Acceder al libre comercio que el mundo
central pregona apostando al desarrollo
industrial
no estoy parado en el lugar
aislacionista en el que algunos me
quieren ver parado pero la Unión Europea
no fue protagonista único de esta
reunión allí También se destacó la
urgencia de que los países
latinoamericanos asuman un nuevo papel
comercial internacional y que no
solamente sean vistos como proveedores
de materias primas es que hay que
recordar que además de Europa ese bloque
exporta principalmente productos
agrícolas a China y a Estados Unidos que
son sus mayores socios comerciales
Daniela hoy se reúne la OPEP más en
Viena con los recortes de producción de
petróleo como telón de fondo Pues Andrés
comenzó esta reunión de dos días con la
presencia entre otros del ministro de
energía de Arabia Saudita también los
ministros de petróleo y gas de Irak y de
Libia y el ministro de energía
infraestructura de emiratos árabes
Unidos todo se reúnen en esta octava
conferencia de la Organización de Países
exportadores de petróleo cuyo tema
principal es la transición energética
sostenible e inclusiva y pues justo en
momentos en que este cartel que ostenta
el 40% de la oferta mundial de crudo ha
anunciado drásticos recortes adicionales
en la producción con el argumento de que
necesitan estabilizar el mercado Esto
fue lo que dijeron
miles de millones de personas dependen
de nuestro producto básico el petróleo
para su vida diaria Esta es una realidad
ineludible que merece respeto
Es por eso que la OPEP Busca la
estabilidad del mercado Por supuesto
como industria queremos asegurarnos de
tener un futuro libre de misiones
aprovechar las tecnologías que pueden
hacer Esto será uno de los temas
predominantes del seminario sin embargo
el petróleo es demasiado central y
fundamental para la vida como para
detener
vamos a hacia Daniela china advirtió que
podrían venir más restricciones a las
exportaciones de minerales Pues
recordemos que estos controles de
exportación sobre los metales utilizados
en los se por ejemplo y en otras
industrias que tiene con los nervios de
punta la industria de alta tecnología
son apenas el comienzo esto lo dijo wey
yangoo quien es el ex viceministro de
comercio y también un influyente asesor
de política comercial de chillín Pink
con la advertencia de que si continúan
las restricciones dirigidas al sector de
alta tecnología de China las
contramedidas van a aumentar esas
declaraciones tienen que ver por
supuesto con las restricciones que van a
entrar en vigencia desde agosto a las
ventas externas de galio y de germanio
estos dos minerales clave para la
industria lo que es visto como un nuevo
capítulo en la pelea tecnológica con
Washington y que se da justamente cuando
la secretaría del tesoro de Estados
Unidos se está preparando para su viaje
de este jueves a Beijing Daniela y vamos
a conocer Cuál es nuestra cifra del día
pues Andrés la cifra es algo triste son
90 años que acumula de historia
panificio panificio es un
establecimiento del barrio
en el Vaticano justo al lado de la santa
sede que es conocido como la panadería
de los papas su dueño Angelo arrigoni
acaba de anunciar que paga apagará sus
hornos pues no pudo sobrevivir al cierre
provocado por la pandemia del covid 19
tampoco a los altísimos costos de la
energía derivados de la guerra en
Ucrania que solamente le están dejando
pérdidas para que lo sepa pues panificio
es célebre por haber surtido de pan
durante casi un siglo a los sumos
pontífices incluido Francisco a quien
Angelo dice que le ofreció hacerle un
tipo de pan argentino pero lo rechazó le
dijo no muchas gracias yo no soy quien
para exigirle O sea que me traiga un pan
diferente a que le vende al resto de la
gente Daniela pues con este dato esa
cerramos entonces la información
económica nos vemos más adelante con la
actualización aquí nos vemos con la
apertura de las bolsas en una hora